Josephine's story is mindblowing really
you first meet her after she has been
released from prison she was a kind of
Outsider just like Napoleon was she met
Napoleon what is this costume you have
on this is my uniform and saw something
in him incredibly ambitious probably
quite
frightening as the course of my life
just changed Napoleon such an insight to
How Deeply they were attached to each
other it was a very interesting power
dynamic think you're great you are just
a brute I had so much compassion for her
because it was a brutal time and he was
brutal to be with I am the most
important thing in the world Josephine
had to be this incredible force of
nature I found her the most remarkable
interesting person she was iconic and I
felt really honored to try and inhabit
her you are nothing without me Napoleon
exclusively in movie theaters November
22nd r r